[Music]
hi welcome to chess on psychology
hopefully today I wanted to talk a lot
about scotch because it's one of those
openings that some people really hate
some people really liked and so I
started working it for its years ago and
I had some nice results indices to Lopez
and four nights and yeah a lot of
different variables to just see what
suits my style more so today I want to
show you some of my favorite games and
[Music]
obviously I got two good results and
obviously I had bad results and scotch
too one fun fact for you just history
lovers Kasparov used to be and hopefully
still is a very big Scotch fan so if you
want to play scotch and then you feel
like on but nobody really plays it look
at the sparks games that's what I did
and yeah we are upstairs today good I
yeah it was very nice I I like the
change of scenery too
okay so let's jump in the first game I
want to show you is with one and only
Tanya Tanya such stuff and this was a
very interesting game this was in like
six years ago actually this game
happened in Iran and I really like Sonya
she's very nice she comes here often to
so well okay let me show you how it went
I remember that I prepared a lot for
this specific game and I thought she
would play like French or caro-kann just
because it wasn't my strongest suit
and then we got into this position and
yeah so usually five and twenty seven
Queen e2 is the normal way to play it
there are other ways to play it too like
I've played around with Queen e2 earlier
just to try and be a little tricky for
my opponents and sometimes they don't
play like Queen seven sometimes they
play like Bishop c5 and that e5 no more
Queen e7 so they would have to start
moving night around so that's something
if you want to be a little bit tricky
but I was comfortable playing what I
knew so here there are a lot of
different lines to go g6 is one of the
main lines and the most played ones g5
when she played g5 fun fact a lot of
theory the main thing that kind of like
the light that went off on and my brain
was this f5 square I just really wanted
to see if I could somehow get this
Knight to f5 and so that's something
that I was trying to do so yeah
hopefully I'm reading through the chats
and I'm trying to yeah well a lot of
difference a lot of interesting comments
and okay the chat is very active glad
about that alright so I tried to just
play normal stuff that I knew and got my
night out
she did this night before and so let's
say white team or what do you want to do
here just give me a few ideas on how you
would want to proceed
for you Lopez lovers I did talk about
Lopez my experience with Lopez earlier
last week or the one before that so feel
free to check that one out too
I'm hoping to get through many games as
possible today to try and cover
different variations night
um King III well John you are funny
nope nice F train no you kind of want to
get the night to g3 so that that was the
idea I wanted to just simply get my
Knights out especially because this is
coming so you got a little move tonight
anyways so Knight f3
there's always G force then what would
you do with the Knights let's say you
play Knight f3 g for your knight doesn't
really have anywhere to go you come to
d4 you lose this guy too so nice f3
would not be the best one I just went
with Knights
efore I think Queenie 4 also could be
very reasonable because if it's white so
you're trying a 3 again whoops not that
now white mass might want to play a 3
but I think when he for I think what I
was a little bit afraid of was something
with like d5 or then take take take with
something and then take back I think I
was a little afraid of d5 and if you try
I'll pass on it doesn't work too because
there's just check at the end power also
it's at the end so a lot of different
stuff to watch out for a lot of
different dropping pieces so Queenie for
with just I thought they will just make
my position a little sadder so I just
went with 94 and after 94 yeah the
a little dirty trick was if you take I
take it whoops no no D five Jesus why is
my mouth jumpy today I would have this
Knight f6 and I would pick up here Queen
so that was my little somewhat of a
trick that I tried to pull off obviously
she saw it and but yeah good good I
jaroslav yeah so after 94 my idea was
pretty simple I am going for this lovely
square she did the long castle I did my
knight g3 because I mean if a train out
then I think this is very very doable
take take now attacking rook so I don't
really know how to get my king sized
pieces out so that's going to be more
pleasant for black so I did my Knight G
395 I got that piece I did my a3 night
went to d5 now what do you think white
should do
Wendy Tanya become well I am i have no
clue but I do think she was and I am
when I was playing with her so it's been
a long time I'm sure you can check it up
on speed there if you're betting I would
say 2010 let's go with 2010
g3 I think I think my biggest problem
was that I wasn't really afraid of
Knight f4 whoops not going to do that
however I was a little bit afraid of
something like d6 or like with f6 so
that's something that I was worried
about
so g3 I think g3 is well doable
especially because if you played d6 I
might be able to give you a check and
pick this guy up if you play f6 however
now it's getting a little annoying
because if I just bring my Bishop outs
you just take on e5 castle and now the
king is also pretty weak just like a
direct attack going so g3 doable I think
but I decided to go with Queen d2 okay I
see clean D - yeah I see Queen d2 in the
chat - great so after Queen d2 do you
think black has any tactics any what do
you think black should do so black so
move right now what do you think black
should do
twenty-eight
all right well I was close that's a 2010
oh well it's blacks you move Jane
Curtis you need to know all of our
agents to become a chess master not
necessarily it's more like understanding
where the pieces belong and being able
to just play good chess I don't know all
the variations you can show me some deep
line in even scotch and I would know
that this is like a scotch position but
I wouldn't know what to do in this yea
rookie 5 would be baby 5 would actually
give black some edge well I wouldn't
take it because if I take Queen takes
and then it's just horrible over here so
my idea was if you take rookie 5 out
working d1 if you play Knight f4 well
now I take I'll put a 2 and it's like a
very uncomfortable position but I was
hoping that I would be able to get
something out of it and because if you
don't finite a4 I'm going to pick up
this Knight
I whoops I'm going to pick up this
Knight attack this guy this guy's pinned
so it would be quite uncomfortable for
black that's why it's it was nice for it
was nice to try and just take on e5 to
make my life a little more uncomfortable
but she didn't she played Knight to f4
now I got my cast oh she got her Knight
back to e6 I'm not entirely sure why 96
I assume because e 6 is coming up and
now white you move what do you want to
do why it's what's getting better and
better so what do you want to do
any kind of black tea would do thank you
sure why not
thank you
so let's see anything for White Queen
high five yeah Queen if I would be
really nice I did through the Queen a5
and so the idea is pretty simple you
move this I'm going to pick up on and
this pawn has come going to be very
monstrous so what do you think we'll
actually do you see any like many
tactics or something for black
so we do want to get this Queen before
and we do want a queen a5 thank you and
we do want to do our best to try and
keep the Queen on a5 King b7 well I
think a problem with King b7 is that
well I'm thinking this bishop is really
misplaced here so if I could just play
p5 b4 b4 b5 and the bishop is falling so
I don't think King b7 works anything a
little trickier King b8 yeah J you are
right King goes to b8 the idea is very
still tricky you got to come back and 9p
Three Forks and gets your Queen right
yeah you are
yeah you guys see it's great lovely so
let's say key so King b8 you can't take
on a six so you're white how can you try
and advance your position you see that
you have advantage slight but still
advantage spacial advantage you have two
bishops you have better a lot of better
space so how do you want to get better
as white as well how can you make
progress thank you guys for putting full
lines so all right
why do you move how do you want to
progress there's not much tactic here
it's more like nice balance between
dynamic and just let's call it
maneuvering yeah this did happen in the
goat in the game it was pretty cool too
so do you see any way to try and bring
more pieces maybe yeah
King bee one whoa you guys are a fire I
think before might be interesting but
it's kind of like it feels like I'm
trapping my own queen
so King bee one is better because so
ideally you would want to try and play
c5 at some point and maybe try and get
this truck up here if possible so now
King b1 now I want to take on a six
because no more ninety five ninety three
right so you move the King to be one you
have this deadly threat of picking up a
piece so she just went back with her
Bishop now we push C 5 C 5 so the knight
can't come in the bishop is open Bishop
c4 C 100 c4 it's a nice flow Queen f8
attacking the pawn rook see one now Roxy
for rook a 4 minus B coming up so she
just played King a 8 keep in mind if I
try to play with c4 let's say she does
whatever I played okay for there's
always Queen c5 so I can't do that just
yet so now another question for my
viewers why to move how do you want to
get more pieces to come in the attack
think about how this rook is not working
maybe or how this Bishop is working but
maybe it could be a little better placed
or is this Bishop because here you want
to leave it there
cool bad bishops now we're talking about
good bishops next one we have bad
bishops haha yeah h4 good one guys so a
little fun story about how I started to
really like this h4 stuff I remember
when I was just beginning to up my level
in chest
I would not move my a and H pawn I just
wanted to keep them there I don't know
why yet I don't have my logic from then
with
but I remember I saw a bunch of Magnus's
game and I was like oh magnus did this
push this pawn and Braque the rope and
wow it actually works so I started to
actually really like it and then I did
it in few games just for no reason like
instead of castellón I put my king on g1
and just put H for registry I mean it
worked and then the idea saved me a few
times in serious rated games that I was
hunting down rating in norms so here's
an idea
but yeah so finally I like this h4 I did
this age 4 so that is pretty simple if
you take it it is going to be very
uncomfortable I don't actually see how
white how black could try and stop this
so she shouldn't take and she didn't so
she played d6 I think it was her best
defense as well because now if I try and
take anything if I start eating pawns
now black can get some room to breathe
and defend here it's it's gonna be
easier
so as wife is crucial not to touch these
pawns and like these kind of pawn
structure especially without the Queen's
on board is something that you see a lot
in scotch games and Kasparov games so
feel free to look a little bit more
deeply on that and get a better
understanding of the pawn structure
because like with d6 or sometimes when
the pawn is on T 5 you usually as white
don't want to exchange it off you don't
want to take it because it would kind of
just fix all back black pawn structure
problems and spatial problems so keep
that in mind - oh hello
come welcome welcome you're just getting
in for the interesting parts so I just
ate that pawn over on g5 and she did
Knight see 595 is good bringing nine
more pieces to protect the poor King
over here so why to move now what do you
want to do you see how nice the attack
is right just try and organize a better
I like to call it organizing Symphony
when you're
attacking your opponent so yeah
organized a symphony tell me where you
want the bishops rooks and preferably
just give me the move or the candidate
moves that you would make in your game
sac the Bishop basics Oh God
already giving up pieces no you still
have a lot of improvement to do
I mean sacrificing is always worth
mentioning and worth looking at but
definitely easier to yep your love
you're right Bishop d4 thank you yeah
exactly you're daring that's night to
move good you're putting pressure you're
also avoiding any kind of other movement
with this d6 pawn with this night you
just paralyze all of these pieces right
here
good job Bishop d4 so she realized that
her position like it's just not gonna
get any better and I'm not willing to
just sacrifice weird stuff it just yet
so she played Queen g8 so Queen g8 is
going for g5 right so it's kind of
avoiding any kind of wreckage for ideas
I remember I thought about something
with Bishop III but then there are rocky
v ideas and we would want to avoid those
so you want this bishop to stay on T for
you don't know what to do with district
just yet Bishop on f1 is good I think if
it was me right now I might have tried
something with like f4 maybe but back
then me I tried something a little just
more simpler so why to move how do you
want to work it I have a question about
isn't might be three or four quell it is
a fork but if you tokenize on b3 a7 is
falling and wait so be careful with that
yeah before I think before it should be
good enough
f4 I think it's also worth looking at
just because it kind of ties blacks
hands up a little bit more but before
should be just enough to win she gave a
check King up she did Queenie for
now whites to move try and give me a
little more precise moves on how you
would want to continue you do you want
to just take it over on a c5 or
basically the question is do you want to
take on c5 or do you wants to play
something like Bishop e3 to save your
Bishop rook c4
maybe yeah rook c4 I think yeah the only
thing with Trixie for to maybe watch out
for would be if there was any pins but I
don't really see any pins right now
maybe something with like Bishop a
snakes so if you take over here take on
here and it's check you got a take and
then d4 foss so you got to probably be
careful with something like Bishop a6 if
you play rook c4 so what else
another question about their war is well
the club is still the city is is still
on lockdown for social distancing so
very few of us come in but if I'm not
wrong the so the city is starting to
slowly open back up from Monday I don't
know if the club is going to be open to
public I don't have that information but
I hope that answers your question
I actually can read that off of it
who dared to do I am answering you
hopefully I pronounced your name correct
- yeah all right so we want to go with
Bishop III good choice good keep your
position steady don't rush into anything
Bishop III is the best one and so after
Bishop III she realized that this guy
this night is falling and there's
nothing she can do so she tried to
create some sort of anything to keep the
position going and make it a little
trickier so she played Bishop c8 her
idea was quite simple if I take over
here now she has check I would have to
move the king somewhere she would create
another check and it would just at least
of all make my position very
uncomfortable so now she wants to play
Bishop e6 what do we do
exchanging bishop for bath yeah well
it's not more of a exchange is more of a
trying to eat the free piece so there
was a question whether cooks at sea for
Bishop a6 oh yeah
if rook C for Bishop a 600 C 5 BC from
Recife well yeah it works if I visit my
Queens about that wins good I but I was
thinking if home on what if DC 5 Quincy
five d4 is falling isn't it alright
Bishop c4 in this position you guys are
correct good job just block the Bishop
e6 very nice I'm going to just jump back
to the rooks c4 because there was a
question about it back here instead of
Bishop e3 or 64 bit of a 6 if you are
talking what rook takes d5 be c5 Queen
c5 this Queen d4 and it kind of stops it
a little bit I mean this is still
advantageous for white sorta but their
Queen b6 and you don't know this is not
sorry it's not a dentist you was kind of
boy or advantage so there could be
Bishop c5 but then you would be giving
different kind of checks and no let's
not do that
rook c4 so the biggest problem with drug
c4 is you would give your opponent
chance to create complications with
Bishop a6
so don't go for it so do this Bishop e3
do this Bishop c4 avoid any chance of
your opponent's trying to get freaky
ideas now this night still can't move we
touch the knight a seven mates right so
she tried to play something with Dirk
takes e5 so when I take she would try to
create something with Mike Bishop a5 any
kind of chance to give any sort of check
and I just took on c7 simply attacking
the rook and now I just really wanted to
keep it simple
and I didn't want to give any chances so
I just played a trick c3 my idea was to
try and just play
Petrey maybe not necessarily even a
repeater you just take over here I think
I was afraid of something like this
route b1 work with black or Klee one
take maybe Queen c2 check up check I
don't remember why I didn't just take
over d6 because black doesn't really
have any checks at the moment so I Rock
City wasn't necessary but was definitely
beautiful to just avoid any kind of
other checks or possibilities yeah and
she took here I play tricky one just not
willing to give up my pieces and I
finally took over here attacking that
and she resigned here because well I
have a one more piece attacking f5 roof
b3 coming up let's say you play
something like Bishop g6 now I have the
beat reef least of all I'm pretty sure
there are other stuff too so yeah this
was a very nice game it was a very
motivational game for me too I do think
I scored the W I am norm in that
tournament cuz 2014-15 and I was still
hunting down w IM norms so yeah this was
the first game i wanted to share with
you hopefully you guys liked it because
it was one of my most interesting games
to just because it just felt like lots
of the moves that i would do now i did
back then too so it just felt like a
sort of i've reached some sort of some
level of chess maturity so i really like
that
okay so this was the first game i wanted
to show you let's move on to the whoops
that was a loud computer so i don't know
how much you see this computer but this
is one of those big laptops with a huge
screen i'm actually have to look like
this to find the left and right
all right let's see give me a second to
see if this is a better one or actually
yeah this is interesting okay so
remember how I was talking about you
having the chance to play Queen e2
earlier before II five so I want to show
you in this game so yeah you remember
yeah this was actually in Reykjavik 2017
I my last European tournaments I can't
wait to go play more tournaments in
Europe but well they aren't eternal is
to play anywhere right now but yeah so I
like 2017
I played lots and lots of four night
and I remember in this game my opponent
was lower than me but he was still a
good opponent and I was just sick of
Scot sick at four night I didn't want to
play it anymore because I oh yeah in
Reykjavik no not to break in I got
didn't play I didn't get a chance to
play much four nights in Reykjavik but
so I wanted to just go with scotch and
just yeah so another fun fact about my
the specific opponents mark Polotsk in I
remember he's I played with his father
in last round of Gibraltar and I had a
worse position but it ended in a draw so
when I saw his name platin I was like I
did I played this opponent like last
month or something and I looked him up I
was like oh no that's his father so that
was also funny I I did this thing that I
looked up his father and just prepared
against his father as well so yeah
that's the backstory for this lovely
game and anyways so I remember that I
didn't want to play like 'if I've I
don't want to go for the main lines
because I are I look when I looked at
his father's game I didn't like what he
played but that's yeah I remember his
the game that I had with his father he
played Petrov so I expect that Petrov
mainly buts well yeah okay so
Queenie - I played this Queen earlier
Queenie to try to try and see if I can
be tricky because I think Bishop c5 is
also a good move and there's like a
bishop before Queen he said there are a
lot of different moves and he just went
with Queen e7 so that gave me an idea
that she was prepared in his what he
five so I wanted to avoid that just
little psychology throwing it in there
about how I was thinking about it in the
game just trying to not get into my
opponent's my opponent's preparation
yeah alright so I did this Knight c3 and
I got this a3 because I just didn't want
this bishop before and so I remember
I've looked up some stuff with
eventually trying to play Knight a4 and
pick up the two bishop but it wasn't the
right time at this moment so I was just
trying to see if I can't try and do
something with my day four or not but
well here's an idea out there there's a
lot of ideas with 90 a 4 and trying to
pick the bishop up in scotch so keep
that in mind
will you ever cover some games and
sketch gambits scotch canvas I did cover
some games with from black side to last
week just drawing some ideas but
probably why not alright so I just
wanted visual III mainly because I was
hoping he would take it and I would just
take with the Queen and I could
potentially think about just getting
this Bishop house now this is a good
Bishop unlike thick lesson from Dennis
Paris coming up this is a good bishop
because well I kind of know what do I
want to do with this I'm going to place
this in d3 maybe c4 someday and it's
going to just it has good
diagonals whereas this bishop it's just
it's so hard to picture this bishop in
an ideal position so I just went with
Queen III and just open in my bishop up
I do think that here Bishop b6 would
have been a smarter choice because now
I'm like well I don't want to take that
because you take it with a and then
Bishop a sixes are coming up because
like take take Bishop a6 could be coming
up so I wouldn't want to do that and so
yeah I just wanted to after Bishop b6 I
don't know what would I do I've done I
think something like g3 might be but 94
take tactics take p6 take care I don't
know g3 would just kind of hunger this
pawn there is a slight chance to just
try and relocate the Bishop again but
let's just say I am glad he did not play
Bishop e6 and finally he got his d5 and
I know not taking on d5 because you're
fixing your pranams pawn structure even
though something with Bishop b5 would
have been interesting because this would
just fix the opponent's pawn structure
so Bishop d3 castle castle rook e8
putting more pressure bringing out the
other rook and so right now White has a
slight edge but it's nothing like it's
not a determining advantage it's just
White's pieces are slightly better
positions so Weiss to move how do you
want to proceed
oh yeah last week was real opus maybe it
would most likely be the week before
that stats we talked about Italian from
black side and
right yeah the weeks are flying by on
another good news while you guys are
thinking about what White's to do I
would like to brag about the fact that I
got an organic chemistry
it's been killing me all semester and
I've been wining and wenting about it on
our streams non-stop so I'd like to give
everybody a piece of thank you thank you
I wish there was like a congratulation
button that I would press straight then
it'll be poof so yeah thank you for
listening to me and keeping up with me
this semester all right you five yeah
you guys are right if I'd so the idea of
mine a four is definitely interesting
and something that I would definitely
look into that as well but right now
this a four pond is getting weak and you
don't want to be forced to take it
so e5 is the move you should look at
yeah night thief Knight g4 and I have a
suggestion about Queen g3 Queen Jeter is
nice but Queen t4 is also good because
let's say if you were like Queen h3 is
also interesting and now because if take
then this doesn't work well because of
here but then like something like g6 and
yeah I would definitely go with f4 so I
think when h3 was something that I
considered in the game but I wasn't so
sure about so I just went with keeping
my clean center and yeah well thank you
I am not as well I am senior to be
alright so he just went with f6 because
well it doesn't work to take now they're
a force I believe yeah so f6 is what he
wants for and okay now White's to move
you think there is any way to try and
persuade him to take some stuff over
here maybe
thank you thank you for all of your
congratulations and yeah it's been a
rough semester
well we're not really going for f6 well
hmm I mean he already played up six she
uh he sorry he already did play up six
so I couldn't stop him from that take F
on Oh be careful
he won we don't want to give that up a
street yeah alright h3 is good I'm glad
you guys are keeping up a street you're
pushing the night if the night goes to
h6 now this night isn't a bad place you
could think about f4 you could just
think about taking and if take take take
just king goes up and now this is this
is very doable I think I would think
more deep and go for this actually so
yeah she he just took Knight takes e5
now White team move do you think f4 is
good and if you do play a four do you
see any way for black to try and get out
of it because f4 seems like you're
picking up a piece right but the
question is are you
this game wasn't actually much
sacrificial it was I found what I
remember it it whence to the end game
and it got interesting there the queen
is not necess it it's not like if the
queen is better than two rooks
it's more about the position and in that
specific position black King would have
been really weak and I would like to try
that all right so look at let's look at
F for the thing is with F for if black
doesn't do anything I'm just picking up
the piece right so but blacks best move
is c5 which he did too because if not
Queen comes back to f2 there's 93 you
take that take that take that
or I'm sorry take that take take take
and you didn't really win anything in
its some not very pleasant
so Queen c5 is kind of forced now Knight
takes D 3 Knight xt3
if you take again it's the same story
just - a piece so you kind of after 92
you do have to take it back and now she
did have the chance to try and sacrifice
but I think the problem was how to week
d5 is and he didn't want that because I
think something like rook e8 give this
check Bishop e6 and this is still
playable for both sides but I'm
comfortable with my position I don't
know how comfortable he would be but
it's definitely like it's playable for
both sides it still is fair fight
so yeah c5 was a nice escape for black
so now he just went with Queen b6 I
kinda have to take it take and I took
that guy so I managed to get one more
pawn in an endgame but the the real
question is that well work the 8th what
do you want to do with white because you
touch the Knights let's say you play
something like Knight c3 there's always
Bishop move and
your planet seems to be falling or if
you take or he can take first take and
just push up at 5 and d3 still seems to
be falling right so we got to this
endgame heat 28 I decided to play d4 to
just wait it out and see what he wants
to do if you play like Bishop b5 I might
have some chances with Knight c3 and try
and keep my pawn but the problem is he
would at his best chance is to take on
e1 and take on h3 now if I try to play
it a little tricky and give like some
checks and take that there's recreate
and this pawn in the game is actually
okay for black yeah so that's something
to dad slipped my mind
sorry I thought I covered the mic
oh god I did my best
sorry Oh God
sorry for your ears well it's not
bleeding so I guess they're fine right
all right great okay okay sorry for
everyone's ears and okay so I did this
d4 just try and keep your tricky and he
just didn't do this Ricki one Bishop h3
so he just went with king f7 first
because of this Knight East 7 he thought
that it's a little bit uncomfortable and
I think he also missed the fact that the
pennant game would be comfortable for
black so hi Martin alright so he played
king of 7 and after king f7 I just I was
just keeping my I was just trying to
keep my pawn as best as I can and I just
came back with the night my idea was if
you touch this Bishop I am going to do
everything I can to keep my pawn because
that one is
I have a chance to win so he played b5
to try and make keep it still
uncomfortable for me and okay take take
rook t1 defending it still trying to
pull some tricks off bringing the king
bring in the king and all right
it is why to move DC any fun tricks how
much longer do we have until this game
ends so I would say 5 10 minutes
something like that yeah guys I
appreciate your coroner humor but it's
not as fun as you think it is but thank
you for your concerns I am healthy last
time I checked so what do you want to do
here with whites
any fun tricks no fun tricks
9c3 all right so the thing is if you do
play Knight c3 you're kind of just
inviting the Kings to come to c4 so it's
better to try oh yeah
JC it's good one Rexy one nice Phil you
play your rook to c1 and you are doing
this tiny trick you got your King in you
push this King away and I you are
looking at some lovely edible pawns rook
b8 to keep the pond now you bring your
King back to d3 to avoid this kind of
checks and I put f5 because I wanted to
just gain the space and some Tempe for
future if needed and but this before
would have been stronger before and I
tad clear advantage because now this
trick has to stay here and defend this
pawn + f5 could come next so F before
would have been more precise but f5 is
also advantageous I just I would just
play the round a little with which pawn
to push and I got my king up to c4 and
then the rest is pretty easy you are
just gonna bring your King back up and
attack the rook like this eat that pond
and push that pond and so now a question
for you guys black to move what do you
want to do do you want to play you want
to take the pawn or do you want to try
your chances with let's say rook d3
No thank you thank you for your kind
words Marcus very nice I'll try to cover
more scotch next week with Bishop c5 and
some of the sidelines - I'll try and
find some good Kasparov games -
hopefully it can be a nice repertoire so
in the game he took on a street but I
think group d3 might have made it
slightly trickier but I mean white has
clear advantage now because I could just
even push and just play king bee tree
but more precise would be to simply play
King c4 and protect my pawn and just
pushed upon so that's something is reka
one any good I mean it's doable but I
don't really see how it would benefits
you because I can just push on a5 or I
think something like rook c5 also very
doable and I'm just gonna keep bringing
my king up and just try and protect it
so that's would be the simplest idea
so after take I started pushing pushing
King up check and I ate that pawn
because I wanted to keep protecting my
g4 pawn and he tried to cut my my king
went for some more edibles more edibles
and so this is there anyone here who
thinks this end game is a draw you know
the fun cliche of Brooklyn games are
always draw yeah I agree this is not
defendable yeah very well said
Dara's love
yeah I'm here B yeah I played with them
boat I have one and a half score we were
one and a half half with Plotkin family
all right
so okay let's say he tries to play King
c7 now I have Rick f8 and I'm just going
to keep pushing this and black doesn't
have any checks to stop that so he tried
to trick Jiwon to try and create some
decent checks hopefully so my idea is if
you keep giving me checks I am going to
run with my king to f6 and I did whoops
no no I gave it up nope I didn't sorry
so he got his king up I got my rook
ready for queening he get a check I run
check i run check well sorry no check
because if you check i run over here or
eat you and the fun fact is if you go
rook e1 now i'm going to play a seven
because if you check if you take i have
check and take take and this is a lovely
winning pawn and game right
i would refer you to my King and pawn
warfare previous classes for pawn and
games alright so he tried with King b6
to try his best and stop up on giving
check King up and now I am still going
to bring this King and try and push the
pawn so my idea was quite clear so he
tried more some checks I mean if you
tried some checks oh my god come on
Mouse
there we go if some checks just king up
six and I mean this is just really lost
you move the rook and I just pushed the
King back to e7 and now my rooks
defending my king and this is a
full-grown queen not a baby Queen
anymore so he went sadder k1 and I still
did the same idea with King f6 and King
g7 so I got my king behind my rook so it
avoids the checks his rook is busy
looking at my opponent defending this
pawn and this pawn is about to get his
coronation so he tried truck c1 just
because now if a7 there's Rick see one
on picking this one up so I just gave a
check f6 now f7 is coming up now you
close it up and you just simply push
there are no more checks nothing and he
pulled one last trick we're taking over
here because if I clean now there is
check and take on a8 which was kind of
actually interesting because he fought
until last minute and I just did there's
Ricky savage a queen and 38 and he
resigned and yeah this is this was a
very fun game that I wanted to show you
guys so that those are just two very
broad ideas to look on scotch if your
opponent plays might have six I tried
them both I like them both I generally
like scotch hopefully next week I'll do
more sidelines with Bishop c5 and maybe
some of the lovely Queen assures that
people keep playing on blitz so yeah
hope you had fun enjoy then as far as
this class right after this and see you
later
[Music]
you
[Music]